hey everybody welcome to Fantasy Valley
part 5 and this is a slightly unusual
start of the video since I want to show
what I've done off screen instead of
jumping straight into the time-lapse
because I've worked on some new areas
without recording it just because it
didn't really work out well a lot of
this is just planning so a lot of trial
and error and seeing where I wanted to
fit things to be able to get into the
real scenery once we get into the time
lapses and making up the rollercoaster
just took so much trial and error and
kind of fitting everything together and
I really wanted to make sure that it was
exactly the way I wanted it to be but in
the end I didn't record it but I'll show
it off right now just before we get into
the time lapse basically this area over
here with the sand is reserved for the
Southeast Asian area so this is where I
work at Indonesia and Thailand kind of
inspired architecture and on the Left we
have the Arabian area and in the middle
of the only part which I'm actually
going to go to right now and which has
bit of a rough draft is the Far East
Asian area so this is where we're going
to basically put China and Japan and
Korea into one big mish mash of a theme
which hopefully is going to work out
well because they are definitely
different styles but we'll see about
that later on and it basically has a big
flying coaster going straight through
the middle of this now I don't spoil it
too much because you'll see me doing
that stuff in the time-lapse that I'll
go into in a bit but the very basic
layout of this is having the coaster
just go on the side of the mountain here
which is going to be like the big
centerpiece of this area and this is
reserved for the larger path works maybe
a ride over here if there's space left
for it and the rest of this will be just
a lot of rock work and Chinese Japanese
kind of gardening and this is all going
to be backstage and the transfer track
for the coaster and on the sides will be
able to connect to the other area so
there will be hopefully one path into
the Southeast Asian area here and this
one's going to lead into Arabia and it
will all be pretty tight and very close
together so I'll most likely end up
having some phantasialand kind of wars
be
via between all of these areas with a
lot of very dense theming but yeah
that's what I'll get into the time-lapse
so let's go now with everything else
already done we can hop straight into
making the first building which is
always interesting since the first
building kind of sets the scene for what
the rest of the theme is going to look
like and it's sort of the prototype of
the theme in that sense except in this
case it's a little bit different I think
since the first building that I want to
work on is a pagoda and you might
remember that I've already made a pagoda
in Planet Coast before but that was an
alpha one and we didn't have all of the
amazing details all of the new pieces
and the recolor ability that we have
right now and I think in hindsight I can
do a lot better than what I did then
so that pagoda was more or less just a
bunch of boxes which we're supposed to
resemble a pagoda somewhat but this one
hopefully should become a court detailed
Asian building and kind of a good idea
of what the rest of the area is going to
look like so the first thing that I
wanted to get into and this is something
that you'll see me doing a lot
throughout this entire theme and because
of this it is also going to be a very
time-consuming thing to do so I hope
you're in the mood for Asian stuff
because we're gonna be sitting through
this for quite a few episodes I'm
basically going to have to make
everything from scratch and that is
really the point here there aren't any
Asian walls there are no Asian roofs
there are no Asian details in this game
yet there are some things that you can
definitely use for it like the lantern
chains but most of it I'm gonna have to
make myself so the first thing that I
needed to do here is actually get some
of those very typical Asian Gables and
curve in corners that I really needed to
have to make Asian buildings and I'm
gonna have to make all of these things
before I actually make the buildings
themselves and almost half of the time
sometimes is going to be sunken into
actually making the pieces to make this
thing happen so obviously in the case of
this pagoda I wanted to start off with
the roof since it is really the most
recognizable distinct feature and also
the one that you can't very easily make
with other pieces like the walls and
windows and things like that
well I'm saying windows but many Asian
buildings don't even have windows say
paper screens and things like that can
always just be made with the wooden
posts and mixing different kinds of
pieces but the ruse was really a very
tough point and I'm super sorry to
anybody who's a game developer or
designer and looks at this and it's
already horrified at the Polly's I'm
gonna have to watch out with all of the
faces and I will actually keep some of
the builds less detailed than I would
have liked to do just because this is
gonna lag up the game way too much if I
keep going this way because obviously
this roof right now is made out of
hundreds of different wooden pieces that
are all really small and have many faces
many of which you don't see but they are
still getting rendered by the game so
this piece alone would be about 300
pieces or something like that there is
no way that I could even upload anything
of these buildings to the workshop
because there are way too many Polly's
in them and yeah I basically want to
watch out and use the least amount of
pieces that I can use to make things
look as convincing as I can here and
there but even so this is going to be
pretty heavy on my PC and I hope the
framerate is also not going to drop too
much now back to the building I just
make those quick walls with the kind of
very quick window looking things I'm not
entirely sure how happy I am with them
but the windows look good enough I think
and I didn't want to get more small
details than I had to in this case and
especially from a distance I think it
looks pretty all right so I'm going with
that and what I wanted to do here is get
the roof support and the roof
decorations that you see on many of
these pagodas in very quickly and that
should be really the base piece for this
and that's really why this is quite a
nice building to make because it's
obviously symmetrical on all four sides
so I just have to make this one piece
and copy that over to all of the four
sides and that is basically one floor
done but also I will actually use this
piece to make the entire
Pagoda you might know that pagoda is
actually have this sort of building up
structure to them like each floor is
slightly wider than the floor above it
so they always kind of tower up which
and is neat for the force perspective as
well because it does make them look
taller but in this case I will just have
every floor be well exactly the same
width is just because it's a lot easier
and I don't have to remake every roof I
might get back to that in the future but
that's probably not going to happen it's
just too much effort and too many pieces
for something which is not even that
visible and I'm quite happy with how the
pagoda looks even with floors of the
same size so I'm probably going to keep
it this way which is one thing that
isn't entirely realistic about this that
will definitely be many of those things
as well but yeah that basically finishes
off the pagoda it's a pretty standard
three story pagoda which I'll talk more
about in a little bit but first I wanted
to get that peak points on the pagoda
pagodas always have like this post on
top of them which is actually like the
central column I believe which goes
through the entire building and keeps
all those all of the floors together I
don't think it actually carries any
weight it's just kind of like a big well
steady pendulum in the middle of the
building that really holds everything
together but they always have these
decorations on totaling which are always
the same decorations and always in the
same order and I definitely can't get
all of them in since we don't have
pieces like that in Planet Coast but I
definitely wanted to get these sacred
rings in there on the post which are
like those round things that you always
see on the peak of a pagoda so I got
those in there quite quickly and that
really finishes off the top of the
pagoda but you might have noticed that
I'm making this like extra piece at the
bottom here and the reason why I still
feel a bit weird about doing this is
that well a few years ago I was told
that pagodas always have an odd number
of stories and at the time I was still
happily making four story pagodas
everywhere which wasn't really good
because well there are a couple of types
of pagodas
like every country has different types
of decoders and they all have different
types within the countries as well but
most of them have an odd number of
stories and this is what you would
usually see and especially the type that
I'm making right now you would
definitely see with three or five
stories but I found this one which had
four stories in a way since it has a
bottom story without a roof on it but
just that big balcony going around it
which I thought was interesting because
it sort of gives the building the extra
height that it needed I was playing with
like how I wanted to layout the pagoda
before I go into this episode and it
really seemed like a three story pagoda
was too low but a five story pagoda was
too tall and a seven story pagoda is
just madness so I was not really sure
what I wanted to do there and in the end
I wanted to raise the rest of the pagoda
by adding that base floor which is a bit
higher and doesn't actually have a roof
underneath it just to give the building
the right height which doesn't
necessarily make the pagoda itself look
better I'm not sure how much I really
liked that floor but it did feel really
important for the placing of the pagoda
for me because basically this pagoda is
super important
in how this area looks not just because
it's a pretty big thing and it's very
eye-catching it also really has a pretty
important role in how the area is laid
out and it's very similar to the pagoda
that I made earlier actually imagine
that if you look onto this area from the
lake or from the path that goes toward
the Asian area everything is kind of
arranged in an order and composition in
a way that I wanted to get done and I
know that sounds all super
planned and everything but it was just a
general idea that I really wanted to get
in here because it just makes the entire
thing look a little bit better basically
what I'm talking about here is that if
you look to this area the first thing
you see in like the foreground is the
pagoda and then just behind that you
have the coaster which is a little bit
taller than the picker
and behind that you have this mountain
which are making the rocks for at this
moment which is again a little bit
taller than the roller-coaster that's in
front of it which kind of gives it that
layered feeling which just helps make it
look like a cool scene in the mountains
with Asian buildings and all that but
also helps make the coaster look a
little bit better like the mountain
creates a bit of a backdrop like a
background to the rest of the area kind
of placing it into a Japanese mountain
or whatever Asian mountain scene you're
going for and the pagoda just involved
the coaster but just a little bit lower
makes the coaster look a bit higher than
it really does because in the end it's
just lifted off about 20 meters and for
a B and I'm flying coaster it's not
actually all that big the only big thing
about it is the first drop and the first
loop where it really dives very low and
really uses the terraforming to get a
lot more speed but the actual lift hill
itself isn't actually that large and
coaster doesn't have that much of a run
time either it doesn't even have a
mid-course brake run so I kind of wanted
to set up this area to make the coaster
look as large as I can while at the same
time getting a cool Asian scene in which
I'm working on at this point I'm lagging
behind again and the other thing that I
wanted to do is of course place the
pagoda on a square base and around it
have a bit of a Chinese / Japanese
garden idea with lava rocks and a lot of
flowers and make that all the cool I
won't get into actually finishing it and
adding all of the vegetation and details
to it quite yet just a sort of general
idea of what this is going to look like
so I can kind of feel like oh that's
gonna work some time and then move on to
other things but um I at least wanted to
get this all laid out in such a way that
I well more or less feel alright moving
on to other things because one last
thing that I still need to do in this
episode to get another year and give you
guys an idea of what this area is going
to look like when it's more or less
finished is make the actual mountain
itself and
we're gonna do something interesting
with this mountain I wanted to have a
small waterfall that kind of comes out
of it just to make it look a bit more
interesting since there isn't really
going to be too much on or about this
mountain to make it look very
interesting it's also nice because it
fills up some empty space which I didn't
really know what to do with since it's
underneath the flying coaster so that's
very cool as well and it just makes
everything look a bit more picturesque
hopefully that was all figuring that the
waterfall would work by the way I
totally forgot
by the way that I met those bunch of
custom plants and custom trees which I
am actually really happy with the new
like dead three things that we go in
scenery because they're super useful for
just putting bushes on dead trees to
make them look like custom trees with
all kinds of textures and shapes that
the actual game doesn't give you so I'll
be playing around with that a bit more
as well but this is basically setting
the scene for the waterfall before we
actually get into making the waterfall
and to make the waterfall I wanted to
get it into morning since every time you
place of waterfall you do have to
unpause the game for a little bit
actually see how this dream is gonna go
and it was quite tricky since these are
water jets and not actually water for
pieces and I wanted to make sure that
the waterfall not only looks like thick
and like it's actually a stream of water
except instead of a couple of narrow
jets that kind of come out of the
mountain but also I wanted to use the
least amount of water jets that I could
to make this waterfall I made one before
this which I was also recording but that
turned out to be a fail because um once
I was finished with the waterfall and I
used way too many water jets for it I
noticed that my FPS are dropped from
like 50 to 28 and 28 is not that bad but
it definitely is really bad when we're
in this early stage of the park so yeah
I wanted to get the lowest amount of
what if jets in here that I could which
maybe it's not the best-looking
waterfall that I could have gone for and
I also have to say it looks a lot less
good in paused mode than it
while just playing it the animation of
the water definitely helps and it still
looks better than I kind of expected it
to be but it's it's not perfect and but
I probably will just leave it this way
to keep my performance at least somewhat
okay
now moving on to the next thing I didn't
just want to have the coaster track
going next to the mountain but not have
it interact in any kind of way so what I
wanted to do and I'm not really sure if
this really has any kind of name or if
this is even anything but very often in
these Chinese Gardens you have these
walls with like an overhanging roof
which hangs over the path that goes
along them and they can look really
beautiful if you have like a staircase
that the roof goes over and it really
follows the terrain in a way and I
wanted to get that kind of idea in in
this lift hill so the lift Hill is not
just a wooden floor but also a roof that
hangs over the coaster which eventually
when the mountain is finished kind of
goes into the mountain like at this
point it's just kind of a floating roof
with nothing attached to it but in the
future it's a roof that really comes out
of the mountain and hangs on the side of
it and yeah it gives something for the
coaster to hang underneath on the side
of the mountain quite simple but it's
something which just makes everything
look a bit less boring and I thought it
was a fun idea
and wanted to play around with it and I
just quickly built the thing here to try
and get the very precise placement that
I wanted I actually had a bit of a
problem with the the coaster I
completely forgot what those things are
called
but basically they're squares that whole
of the catwalks of the coasters since
they were poking through the roof and
there is no way to really get rid of
that completely so there's a still a
tiny bit that pokes through the roof but
still I'm really happy that I added
those things in alpha-3 that's
definitely a very good addition when it
comes to realism but at this point they
were kind of annoying
now finally making the actual mountain
itself to get an idea of what that thing
is going to look like it's gonna end up
being a bit taller than the coaster
itself
I wanted to use actual rock work from
the game for this instead of
terraforming there are a few reasons why
I wanted to do this one reason should be
very obvious I still suck at the
terraforming tool and terrible edits I
try to make like a mountain with a lot
of like detailed rock work with the
terraforming tool and that turned into
disasters so that's one thing that we're
not doing but also it has that different
texture which you can't exactly get with
the terraforming tool and just those
rough sides on the side of these rocks
that really give it this very jagged
kind of rock texture to it not just when
it comes to the texture but really the
shape of it is something which you
cannot get with the terraforming tool
and I'm just most happy with how it
looks with these rocks the only thing
that I'm concerned with is that it might
lag up the game a lot which would be
pretty bad so I'm trying to keep my rock
usage still as low as I can and the
terraforming at least right now is a
guideline as to where the rock work is
gonna go so I don't end up with any Rock
work that's not really necessary but
it's still placed and that'll just add
extra lag into my game but you know
still this is not a very PC friendly
alternative to terraforming that's one
thing that I do have to keep in mind and
our supporting is also a pretty
interesting thing you might have noticed
that a large part of the coaster is not
actually supported and I want to get
some custom supports in on the coaster
itself not just this roof thing that I
have going on the lifter which I'll get
into in a bit and the reason for it was
more or less that I lost many supports
just because of the way that this
coaster is built but also many supports
are actually turned off on many sections
obviously I went into ton of supports on
the lift Hill since I wanted to make
this roof thing I also wanted to turn on
supports on the drop because the
supports of the flying coaster in the
inverted coaster are still really wide
and they go everywhere you don't want
them to go
and in this case they would have gone
straight through the pagoda that's not a
very good idea but I think in the end
it's actually much more fun to try and
make some custom supports than just
using the in-game ones because you can
kind of make them part of the theme in a
way more interesting way than just these
colored steel beams that you could find
in any Six Flags do so I'll get into
some wooden supporting in a little bit
and talk a bit more about that first I
needed to get a few more walks in here
and there I'm going to do much of the
rockwork kind of spread out over a bunch
of episodes that I'll be having about
this theme just because it's not the
most interesting thing and there's going
to be a lot of rock work and even if
it's interesting for you viewers to
watch it is definitely not interesting
to be doing hours on end so I'm trying
to at least spread that out a little bit
and add as much foliage as I can around
it to to make it look a bit more
interesting and in general if if your
work work will expand in any kind of
particular place it's just like
buildings just add a bit of foliage over
it and it's gonna look good eventually
you just have that corner where the rock
work and it sticks out awkwardly or you
don't really know how to make the shape
look good just put a big Bush in there
and it's fine but yeah finally it's time
for the supports and I wanted to kind of
get some wooden supports in here make it
look like real unique supports instead
of trying to make it look as close to
the in-game supports as I can because
there's no way to actually make it look
like the in-game supports but also this
is a bit more interesting I think since
it has that sort of Mountain Asian well
not all that safe wooden structure to it
which in real life I would probably say
they should be steel supports with a
wooden texture painted on them which is
actually a thing which is really nice
but that's it for this time lapse so I'm
gonna close this video off with a few
cinematic shots and I'm see you guys
later bye bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]